We asked you to vote for the 2017 movies.
You wanted us to make an honest trailer for. Here's your number four pick. You guys are weird...(obviously)
From the mind behind films such as; Requiem for a Dream, Black Swan, and Noah. Comes a gruesome...
..paranoid Bible allegory, which is kind of what you should expect by now from the mind behind Requiem for a Dream, Black Swan, and Noah.
mother!
Experience a gripping tale about...
something... Where this... mother, and this... guy, have some increasingly bad house guests.
[Clip: Leave me alone. You're an arrogant *bleep*]
Stuff happens...
Then slowly but surely, everything goes cuckoo-bananas-not-so-great
What is going on?! Stop making me feel dumb movie! You're the dumb one.
Stroke your chins for what's either a retelling of the Bible from nature's perspective, an allegory about global warming,
a meditation on the creative process, a critique of traditional gender roles,
or a story about how hard it is to date a famous person.
In this film that refuses to answer basic questions about plot or character
But does tell you what Extreme Home Makeover would look like if it were directed by Satan. Move that bus!
Move it back! Move it back!!
Witness gruesome imagery that will disturb you to your very core
where a baby being eaten alive is nothing compared to a close-up of Javier Bardem smiling,
[Clip: *Gasps* You scared me.]
Kristen Wiig acting serious,
[Clip: The Inspiration.]
and unprepared public speaking.
[Clip: Would you say something?]
See this is my actual worst nightmare.
Follow Jennifer Lawrence's giant face around for half the runtime as she takes on a non-stop barrage of household chores,
generally walks around,
and stares at the wall.
But if that sounds boring, wait until you hear what her husband is going through. He's a poet
with
writer's block.
Whoaa
Man, this movie sounds like it was written by a guy with a lot of scarves...
Oh, right
So dive in to the esoteric film that audiences either loved,
hated, or really hated. In this film that looks and sounds beautiful,
avoids easy categorization, and really makes the audience think.
[Clip: It affects everyone in a different way. It is remarkable.]
But sometimes feels like the whole thing was dashed out over a long weekend. Because... it was.
Starring:
Hunger Games literally Catching Fire
No Country for Old Testaments
Dread Flanders
Catty woman
a Mcpoyle brother
what it feels like to host your in-laws
and *echoing voice* the forbidden sink!
[Clip: That sings not braced yet. Could you get down from there? That sinks not braced yet. Get down from there.
Please get down from there. Please.
Stop doing that. Don't do that. Stop! Stop doing that!]
We get it already: Don't sit in the sink. Jeez, you're not my real mom.
Big Momma's House 3
If there's one thing you can count on in a movie, it's that a writer working in isolation will always go insane.
I asked Alexa a question in a dead language and she opened the gates to hell
banana crumpets
Somebody once told me that I was Mike Wazowski.
I'm just a porg boy from a porg family
Eating Tide Pods doesn't make you cool